but we know how technology works you
take something that used to require some
skill some expertise and you make it
easier right I don't know how to work a
satellite but I have a cell phone if you
make it easier for people to press a
button and print a gun
getting around court orders and getting
around gun regulations of all kinds do
you not have some responsibility for
what those people do with those weapons
so there's two questions did I make it
easier and what happens if I did make it
easier I empirically it's a question I
don't believe that today you printing a
gun is easier than your going to buy a
gun you're going to illegally make a gun
from other tools are you just finding
one on the street or something you could
trip over guns in this country right
kids kids on the streets find them in
trash cans okay this is not somehow 3d
printing is now like opened up the
debate the other part is well and then
don't you bear that responsibility
look I am a marginal at best player I
sit here in a warehouse in Austin Texas
I've contributed to what over five years
hundreds of thousands of downloads how
many times have you come in here and
asked me about the times when people
have used that gun they haven't used it
so it's an empirical question put the
philosophy books away put the
Constitution hold on hold on put the put
the seminar discussion to one side and
answer me this when somebody downloads a
gun from your website with your
blueprints and kill somebody with it how
are you going to feel personally I don't
believe that I if I allow you to
download an air 15 the full plans on air
15 I don't believe that I provide you
anything other than the general
knowledge of what an ar-15 is I've given
you no productive capability you have to
take it all that way yourself I am no
different from a publisher of
information hold on you also sell a
milling machine that allows people to
finish the lower you have you have to
understand the debate the file on my
site which everyone wants to stop they
go into these it is for a 3d plastic gun
I guess no you don't get it it's I have
10 files right only one of those is 3d
printable and it's that little pistol
that's my little diamond my little
demonstration the file for the ar-15
which we're talking about in this
example those are the full technical
plans for the ar-15 that's how they've
looked in computer a design for who
knows as long as there's been computers
to aid design if you have that
information you're no more enabled to
make it then than any other manufacturer
gunsmith in this country
to put in all that effort all that time
he still have to understand how to do it
I didn't make that easier but I did give
you the key if you did want to
understand to make it and I will not
apologize hold on you didn't make it
easier no I gave I gave you the plant
you can see what an atom's like that
would make it easier my brother if you
can see when our air 15 looks like that
doesn't mean you understand how to make
it if I own a 3d printer I can make the
Liberator that you have on your site if
I buy that milling machine behind you
from you I can make an ar-15 you can
finish an ar-15 lower receiver with NC
code this is another conversation this
is a whole separate conversation
it is a separate conversation but it's
underneath the banner of your goal is to
make guns as readily available as
possible is that not your goal I want to
benefit the American Rifleman in his
legal pursuits you can make an air 15 in
this country you can understand how to
make an air 15 you can examine the plans
whenever 15 none of these are sanctioned
activities they are all expressly legal
and have always been in your court
filings you've argued that it's in the
public interest everything you're doing
absolutely walk me through your thinking
on that think about this
the minute any government authority
under any color of law tries to impede
publicly protected speech it's against
the interests of all Americans de facto
I think people look at your First
Amendment argument and think it's a
clever way to win a legal battle I think
the reason there's a conversation right
now the reason you have more than a
dozen attorneys general fighting you is
because you're trying to enshrine the
Second Amendment forever
to provide a guarantee beyond the
Constitution that no regulation will
limit anyone's access anyone's eyes to a
firearm that's that's not that's not an
unfair description right I do I am a
Second Amendment
partisan if you will right I believe
what I'm doing immeasurably enables the
Second Amendment it immeasurably expands
it in a technical error right it allows
our culture to move into the Internet in
the 21st century what I'm not allowed to
believe that I'm not allowed to advocate
for that I got to just sit down with
some NGO says no we don't think you
should well I think you should we can't
have organizations that are on my side
of the other debate I don't know how to
make a gun but I do know I've seen you
talk about how I could buy that thing
behind you and make one
it's a great question so so would you
would you like to know how to make the
gun yes or no like you you can choose
that you don't want to make it you get
to make that choice for someone else I
don't think you do I think you know
who's gonna get access to these weapons
but look what I just gave you as a
fundamental question you know that
there's a difference between me and a
gun seller you know it but you want to
make it like it's the same thing no I
guess I do agree there is a difference
between you and a gun seller a gun
seller has a heavier political burden
there are laws in place stopping that
gun seller the reason we're having this
conversation right now is because you
have the ability to publish these plans
without restriction and there are people
who are fighting you on that without
restriction when you say it I think
people are gonna hear something
different than what that legally
actually means does it or does it not
mean that a person who can't get a gun
because of a court order because I've
been beating their wife can get it from
you get the intellectual property
necessary to build a gun from so that
court order right does that prevent
people from reading books on guns at
that point does it prevent people from
downloading plans on guns it doesn't so
what I'm a felon let's say taking the
gas a I'm a felon now I can no longer
learn about certain things in science I
can no longer I can only read books on
sorry you know what I mean like you can
draw a line oh really so all of our up
to nuclear fusion people can make
nuclear weapons okay if they have their
eight if you read the books and you want
to right away if you want to great look
no no this is if you want to if you want
to enrich uranium in your bathroom you
know and you have the technical
knowledge you know it's free speech you
know that practically speaking this is
very difficult but if I knock over the
liquor store do not have the right to
learn about nuclear fusion and become an
engineer for the army at some point
later in my life you would say no once
you you're making it me it's not me I
know it is you it's in your question I
question know my question is settled
American law on speech right on the
rights the speeches speeches constantly
being debated publishers do not have
these none of these laws Whoville or
licenses to speak in this country that's
how it works that's how it's always
worked it worked in cryptocurrency and
encryption because there are dual uses
for those technic
oh geez this is a different can of worms
the state if you're gonna use dual use
on me the State Department makes that
designation the State Department in this
case has made the designation that arms
up to 50 caliber don't have a military
use is a trump administration your
friend and all this I believe the Trump
administration has nothing to do with
this this is this is a settled arms
Export Control reform initiative which
is lasted for 10 years more than 10
years in my understanding so why the
sudden reversal from the State
Department which was fighting you for
years in court there was no reversal
this is all marketing why do you bribe
settlement it's not an abrupt settlement
as recently as April they were fighting
you in court the settlements not abrupt
the the procedural posture of the case
was always on an injunction question we
got to a point where and when these
rules were finally announced when they
were finally ready the DOJ would have
been in the uncomfortable position of
literally allowing this for the American
public but suing one company in the
country I you would have been worse off
if they didn't make the settlement I
would have won that's free and clear at
the Supreme Court in the First Amendment
now that there's so much attention on
this case and on your company what do
you think the future holds I think
there's every reason now for people to
lay down or like a DOJ not to defend
this or something but ultimately should
matter if the judiciary you know is what
it's supposed to be this is pretty easy
I mean I got a license from the federal
government to speak you've said in the
past that if there's some sort of a
change and and and the authorities come
here to take your files to shut you down
that you would call out a militia that
was that was a counterfactual but no of
course I always follow law
I've always ever fought a law in this
country and this is what I think burns
people like I've always pursued licenses
with the with the ATF I have a license
with the State Department right I know
what it is to be a regulated publisher
to be a regulated seller of even my
equipment here under the Commerce
Department I screen people according to
every law every article that I'm
supposed to I participate in ATF Special
Investigations I respond to subpoenas
from the different US Attorney's around
this country
I am nothing if not compliant with every
single law and every single power that
has the jurisdiction over me why do you
think people call you one of the most
dangerous men in the world they thought
you've been named that twice by national
magazine people need something to
by probably so you're giving me the Joe
Namath on these lawsuits guaranteed
victory no I'm not saying that you think
you're gonna win you know how the
judicial process is it's a very
political process but I believe
ultimately we have the law on our side
and I think the hill is even greater now
from the climate our enemies should have
should have intervened years ago right
but now it's it's convenient too because
what it's easier to mark it on and it's
easier to advertise about it if the
political winds shift and your operation
is threatened are you prepared to take
up arms no look the political winds
shift every three four years I'll sit it
out I built this company under more
adverse situation right I built this
company during the Obama presidency I
have to ask because of the the arm
dripping blood yeah yeah holding a sword
classic Texas symbol right
it shows the result of like the the
Texan conscience we would fight we would
waste our money we would build these
things even though we know it would ruin
us that's what that symbol means back
there I'll stand here and help people
and give them this information even if
every Attorney General in this country
pulls me into every venue and ruins me I
know that even if tomorrow somebody
downloads one of your guns makes it and
commits a heinous act
look I accept that that's a possibility
I accept it I believe that there's
enough now we've gone over this multiple
times man you're not gonna show you
accept that it's a possibility you're
just not gonna shame me in there not
speaking I won't be shamed yeah this is
where shameless in this in this sense
when you smile like that I think people
don't cuz that's deep you're giving me
TV models all your shape you know look
and I get the game okay but I think
something of what I believe in will come
through here I believe I radically in
what I'm doing I won't stop what I'm
doing
you're not gonna shame me out of doing
it what I'm doing is legally protected
you can convince some judge or some
district court that I have to stop I
will go to the appellate level I will go
to the Supreme Court I will waste all my
time and perhaps that's the goal to get
me to waste more time more years all
this stuff do everything you can to
fight me fine what I'm telling you is
I'm here to do it and there will be
people after me and the internet serves
our interests and will allow us to do
this easier then you could ever stop it
take me into the future if your vision
is successful what does it look like I
mean since I succeeded them in a sense
it's already happened do you know what I
mean
my vision was years ago well one day you
could just download this stuff easy in
one place and you have access to these
things and the gun culture can kind of
blossom from it because now instead of
me digging around in machine shops and
looking for plans I just know where to
go to get them it's like an encyclopedic
resource in a sense that happened what's
the future that looked like I don't know
I think it becomes easier to become a
small business and firearms it becomes
easier to make custom parts and things
like we see in 3d printing what does 3d
printing actually add it doesn't replace
traditional processes but it adds you
you can more rapidly prototype you can
more actively customize it it takes this
this promise that it gets every other
industry and it gives it to our industry
as well impracticality anywhere there's
a computer there'll be a gun that's the
future I've said that I that's like the
radical libertarian possibility of it
right you know a you know a gun in some
sense is downloadable what this means is
there's no one standing between you and
your computer there's no one standing
between your computer and the printer
right these decisions are right for you
or the printer can make a gun the
printer can make the parts of a gun off
some guns yes this can happen mills can
make these parts because of things
you've said in the past I have to ask
this question what do you say to people
who think you're a radical and an
anarchist who only wants to watch the
world burn everything I do here is
constructive I have built more I employ
more I've produced more wealth and
interest intellectual property I'm a
builder so to be clear your goal is not
to take down the federal government to
be very clear if the attorneys general
succeed in their lawsuit they would have
cut through and burned way more of our
legal structure than I have I have
simply abided by what is petitioned to
the authorities about what should be
never cut any corners legally I have no
state power right I'm not a state
I can't interrupt your access to these
things I build things somebody coming to
this conversation for the first time
turning on their TV today what do you
want them to know about who you are what
you're doing
I want people to know that that we're
friends of freedom it's about freedom
for us and this is the most consistent
and wholesome American purpose and set
of ideas that there's ever been yeah we
come from Texas maybe we disagree about
what freedom means